at one day old Max is not only the
source of joy for his parents as one of
Ukraine's newest citizens is also a
symbol of Hope for a country locked in
war yes there is a war but life goes on
and the birth of a child no matter how
we plan it it's never going to be 100%
And we need to
continue we have the two blocks as I
mentioned Dr Natalia zuk is an
obstetrician at the country's leading
maternity hospital the families um
frankly to be frank they are broken it
is it's just like broken and it will
have the real real bad impact on our
demographic situation even for families
not separated by the war the pressures
and anxieties caused by it are forcing
many to put off having children just
after the fullscale War Began nearly two
years ago the birth rate which was
already low because of the pandemic
dropped by by more than a quarter
threatening to worsen Ukraine's
demographic imbalance with 30% of the
population now being pensioners the
problems of a future population
imbalance that Max and his generation
will likely be tackling for much of
their lives Rob McBride Al jazer
Kei make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer